this looks more complicated I know but
now let's write the first principles
that goes with this guy because this is
the real function I'm interested in not
some random F G whatever I want sine X
that's what I really want okay hmm limit
as I want the run to get really small
right so what's the run in this case
it's 2h yeah
is that okay I want it to get really
small what's the rise have a look
I'm not thinking about F as a general
idea anymore I'm thinking about a
specific function I'm thinking about
this guy so the first thing on my new
mode will be sine of X plus h takeaway
what's the bottom part for the rise sine
of X minus H the UK with that that's
that's the rise okay
what's the run it's going to be two H we
already worked that out okay now can you
see yet do you see why I made this
strangely complicated first thing I want
to do is I'm going to just um if 2 H
goes to 0 what does H go to if 2 H
becomes 0 then H is also going to be 0
right do you agree with that like half
of something really tiny also something
really tiny so I'm just going to write
the limit as H approaches 0 okay now if
you're a teenage student you don't know
what to do with this because you're like
I haven't learnt anything that I can do
to simplify that but you are not to unit
students you are extension 1 students so
you know you can do something with this
right it's why we reviewed at the
beginning is talking for AP threes what
do I do with this I can expand this it's
going to be sine X cos h plus
yeah you can write it I tend to write
the angles in order and keep them but
you can doesn't matter which way you
switch it I'm gonna write cos x sine H
that's okay I'm sort of out of space on
my column here so I'm gonna be a bit
naughty I'm gonna go to the next line
I'm going to minus this thing right what
is this thing it's very similar isn't it
it starts the same way but it's only
difference is
are you okay with that there's the
numerator that's that whole thing is the
numerator okay
the denominator hasn't changed I haven't
done anything to that because there's
not much to do yeah are you okay with
that
oh look look do you see it yet has it
collapsed in your brain yet the reason
why I went and made X plus h and X minus
H is because how what's it called again
when you have like thirds like this you
want to all you want to do something
denominator what are you doing this you
multiply by the by the conjugate right
root 5 plus 1 when you have conjugates
the reason why they just go together is
because things just cancel out what
cancels out this it you see this is the
same as this do you see it so it's gone
right what do I get left with on the
numerator hold on I better I better
write that limit first I've got this
twice over write 2 cos x sine H what's
the denominator well I'll get there in a
second one for the denominator 2 H okay
these two will kick these two twos will
cancel they're gone now
this whole limit has to do with H right
this whole limit has to do with H so
what happens to cause X it's not a trick
question
what happens to cause X when H changes
look like what does it care about the H
and the answer is it doesn't care it's
independent of the H does that make
sense so therefore I can take it out
just like an integration you're like oh
there's a there's a constant there it's
independent of what I'm integrating so
I'm going to factor that out yeah and
then I'm left with this in the limit
what's on the numerator
signage on H now do you remember we did
that first graph underneath this heading
and I said you must draw this in radians
remember we said Jude in radians don't
think value in degrees why why what can
I do with this if I'm in radians in
radians and radians only that's one
right if it's in degrees you can try and
put some values in here if your
calculators in degrees mode you will not
go to one you'll go to some weird thing
I'm Canadian PI or something like that
doesn't work out but in radians I'm
actually going to put a big note on that
because you should - in radians that
limit is 1 so at last
turns out our intuition not so bad huh
the derivative of sine X is cos x
very nice now I said we were going to
focus on derivatives today so we're not
going to talk about the integrals of
this yet but from here there are two
other derivatives you can get quite
easily which are also just as important
like sines only one of the three main
functions right so what are the other
two
let's do cos now when you're trying to
solve for something that you are you
don't know about right there one of the
great mathematical strategies in all of
Matt's is to turn something you don't
know into something that looks like
something you do know right so how could
I turn a cosine into a sine do we know
an identity that could help us with this
think think you've actually got a few
choices right you could use the
Pythagorean identity which is this one
it's not a bad idea because it has both
of them in one line but the problem with
it is you don't just get sine to you you
get sine squared and then you introduce
you have to take square roots and then
you've got plus or minus and then your
brain starts hurting right is there
another identity that I can use that
also connects sine and cos in an even
simpler way without introducing any more
functions just signing cos what does the
code in cosine stand for again
it stands for complimentary so what's
cos x in terms of sine what's the
complement of X it's I'm in radians I'm
in radians isn't it PI on to minus X
that's the complement isn't it
so could you how do we have enough
knowledge to deal with something like
that
now admittedly this is a bit tricky and
a bit cruel to do after an exam review
but I think you can
this is chain rule this into it isn't
this chain rule there's a function of
another function what's the derivative
of the inside there's the inside what's
the derivative this thing tell me what
the different a derivative of Pi on two
is it's just a number
what's the derivative of minus X its
negative one that's the derivative of
the inside what's the derivative of the
outside it's it's it's cos right that
should be x right wait wait wait wait a
second this is the compliment right but
so is this so is this so what is this
going to be equal to this is just going
to be sine if you can't remember that
identity if you'd like you can go the
long way around and you can say I can do
the same expansion here that I did over
here right I can say if I'm not content
to just go from that line to that line I
can say what's the identity for cos a
minus B pretty sure it's because a cos B
is a minus there so what's in the middle
you remember it's a plus and then it's
sine a sine B do you remember that is
the ring a bell what's cos PI on - sorry
my own - that's zero what's sine PI on -
it's one which is what I said okay